(slow piano music)
- I needed to give my life purpose
after bein' wrongfully
incarcerated for 17 years.
I was illiterate; I
couldn't read at the time.
But when I started to learn how to read,
it changed my life and it
actually put me in a position
to be empowered enough to wanna fight
for my innocence and for my freedom.
My name is John Bunn, and
I help promote literacy
in schools and prisons.
(slow piano music)
When I was 14 years old,
I was wrongfully accused
and convicted of a crime
I had no knowledge of,
I had nothin' to do with.
(somber music)
It led to me being
incarcerated for 17 years,
and then on parole for another 10 years,
which was a total of 27 years
of me fightin' for my life.
(slow piano music)
In the beginnin' stages,
I was under the impression
that the system was gonna come to my aid
because I was a innocent man.
The deeper I went into my incarceration,
the hope started to fade away.
When I went to trial, my lawyer told me
any questions or anything I had,
to write it down on a piece of paper.
And I sat there and
couldn't write anything
because I didn't know
how to read and write.
So it was like I sat there
and watched my whole life
flash before my eyes.
So it like ignited a fire
into me to learn how to read.
(upbeat orchestral music)
When I was in prison,
there was a teacher there
that started showin' me
how to sound words out,
and take a special interest
in me, givin' me dictionaries
and children's books to
get me over the barrier.
The process of learnin'
took about 18 months.
Readin' was definitely a
positive experience for me;
it still is to this day.
I found that it was a lot of guys
that had this literacy issue.
Because of my ability to read and write,
I was able to help out other inmates
and enhance their abilities.
(door rattling)
(lively orchestral music)
In 2018, I was able to get
that wrongful conviction
fully exonerated from my record,
and now my life has new meanin'.
When I actually got released,
I started A Voice 4 the Unheard,
which is a literacy program.
It started out as a book drive.
I collected over 80,000 books,
and I distributed the books
to everywhere you can imagine,
from youth detention
centers to Rikers Island
to Boys Clubs to community centers.
(bright orchestral music)
Today, we're about to
donate thousands of books
to Friends of Island Academy
for them to be able to distribute.
And they're gonna also start
a new library in their hub.
- Friends of Island Academy's
a nonprofit organization
offerin' advocacy, support and services
to age 16 to 21-year-old youth
affected by the criminal justice system.
I met John Bunn, and immediately, I mean,
just connected to his story.
And so when I sat down with him,
I just felt his passion, his sincerity.
It wasn't a hustle; it was somethin'
that was really on his heart,
to give to young people
and to really utilize
literacy as a tool to connect.
(stately orchestral music)
- Literacy is freedom,
freedom of your mind.
It's like you unlock your mental chain.
Your mind get the privilege
to wander the four corners of the Earth.
It's magical to me, to be in
a position to be privileged,
able enough to do somethin'
positive; that's priceless.
(gentle orchestral music)
(bright electronic music)